[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckmeyer after weeks of
testimony jurors in virginia reach a
monumental verdict in the johnny depp
versus amber her defamation lawsuit the
jury has found both johnny depp and
amber heard liable awarding the higher
amounts of damages to depp the decision
for death was read first
mr depp's claim against ms hurd
as to the statement appearing in the
online op-ed entitled amber heard i
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
in the washington post online edition
quote i spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
quote then two years ago i became a
public figure
representing domestic abuse and i felt
the full force of our culture's wrath
for women who speak out end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
quote i had the rare vantage point of
seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse
end quote do you find that mr depp has
proven all the elements of defamation
answer yes
as against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars
as against amber heard
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of five million dollars
the verdict on amber herd's suit was
read second jurors fall in depth didn't
defame heard in some of the statements
made by depp's attorney adam waldman in
the daily mail but they did rule depth
defamed heard with one statement
as to this statement appearing in the
april 27
2020 online edition of the daily mail
quote
quite simply this was an ambush a hoax
they set mr depp up by calling the cops
but the first attempt did not do the
trick
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property
so amber and her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up
got their story straight under the
direction of a lawyer and publicist and
then placed a second call to 9-1-1
end quote
do you find that ms heard has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
has ms heard proven by a greater weight
of the evidence that question mr waldman
while acting as an agent for mr depp
made or publish the statement
answer yes
do you find that ms heard has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that the
statement by mr waldman was made with
actual malice answer yes
as against john c depp ii
we the jury award compensatory damages
in the amount of two million dollars
as against john c depp ii
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of zero dollars
joining us today is legal analyst dr
tracy pearson and co-host terry austin
tracy many people anticipated that depp
would win but can you make heads or
tales of how heard was successful on one
of her claims
i think so
when you look at the statement i think
that what it comes down to is that there
wasn't third party evidence to dispute
that
the there was a a conspiracy between the
friends and and amber heard um i also
think that there wasn't third party
evidence to dispute that johnny depp
attended uh the uk uh uh daily mail
meeting
so it's interesting see how that plays
out the big question for you now terry
is what's next for deb in collecting
damages and other potential legal issues
between herd and depp
so after the judge read the judgment she
basically said look it's going to be
entered it's going to be entered june
24th and she asked
depp's attorney to please prepare it and
circulate it for approval
actually i think there is obviously
going to be an appeal but they could try
to settle the case and frankly
death is owed 10 million 350 000 it
would be 15 million but it's 10 350
because it was reduced because of the
cap on punitive damages heard owes 2
million
and uh or vice versa um and and so the
net comes out to eight 350 and i think
they could settle for that amount quite
frankly and i think
you know that might make some sense
meaning that depp wouldn't have to pay
anything at all because the net is owed
to him because he had the bigger verdict
so we'll see yeah tracy real quick we've
got a few seconds do you think they'll
settle or appeal based on what we're
hearing from terry
i think it's possible they would settle
um i i know that i've heard that they're
going to appeal but i think it's
possible that they would settle um if if
they're smart all right we'll see how
this goes maybe we have a whole other
case on the appeal uh in the johnny depp
versus amber heard part two and we'll be
back at that if not i tend to agree with
you both more likely than not they
settle but we'll keep eyes on that
development as it continues still ahead
on law and crime daily our complete
coverage of the johnny depp versus amber
heard trial continues what attorneys
from both sides had to say after the
monumental verdict was handed down
[Music]